well good afternoon everybody and
welcome to the Thursday October 10 2019
session in our series on edge computing
where we're trying to explore whether
the US and Asia are going to go in
different directions
I'm Richard Asher I direct the u.s. Asia
Technology Management Center we produce
this series I also want to recognize the
member companies in our industry
affiliates program because they are our
primary source of support that's how we
get along including salaries and
everything else that we do thanks to
their support we'll have some
refreshments outside after the session
is over and we hope that you will come
and meet some of the people from our
companies are here today and you can see
the list of who's involved in a chart
outside so we started off I gave an
overview a couple of weeks ago and last
week professor Paul Raj talked about 5g
networks so the next kind of major
enabling technology for edge computing
is really AI processing chips AI or
chips computer chips that accelerate AI
processing and also reduce power and so
on and so forth we have somebody I'm
absolutely delighted to introduce to
speak to us on this topic exactly the
right person again Gary Brown was one of
the very first research assistants I
worked with at Stanford before many of
you were born Garriott was a master's
candidate and electrical engineering at
the time and we were working on reading
Japanese technical literature in
Japanese and providing reports on that
to the Silicon Valley community and some
of what we did led to us being the first
place outside Japan that Professor Shuji
Nakamura presented his work on blue LEDs
he hadn't even developed the laser at
that point
so I'm really happy that I can ask Gary
to come back and speak to us after
graduating he became a field engineer he
worked with Dolby labs then he did
engineering sales support for several
startup companies moving up to bigger
and bigger sized startups until he got
to ten silica and then from ten silica
he went to a company called mo videos
which was one of the prime movers
startup companies in chip acceleration
and a couple of years ago Intel bought
out new videos so now Gary is the
director of AI marketing for the IOT
group inside Intel and he also has
extensive international experience I'm
glad you could be in country this time
in order to talk to us Gary thanks so
much for coming a pleasure dr. - sure
Richard it's great to be on the Stanford
campus back when I was a master's
student I got to hear a talk by Gordon
Moore many of you have heard of Gordon
Moore at least you've heard of Moore's
law that was named after Gordon Moore
and he gave a brilliant speech here as a
part of a hot chips microprocessor
symposium when the only thing I'll say
about it is the reason why it was so
brilliant it had nothing to do with
Intel it had to do with the industry and
the challenges that the industry is
going through and the promise of being
able to develop faster and faster micro
processors which everybody in this
industry was focused on and what a
brilliant talk to be able to speak to
the industry about what we all have to
do together rather than to focus on what
your company is doing so many times when
I'm speaking I like to try to educate
about what's going on in the industry
and take the focus a little bit away
from my company but focus on you know
things that everyone has to do and maybe
provide a few examples along the way of
what we're doing at our company for for
to be you know more of an education
because I mean after all this is a
university but I wanted you to think for
a second have you ever walked along the
street I've done this before and closed
your eyes and tried to remember where
things were on the street and imagine
what it would be like if you were blind
there are many many blind people but if
you do that yourself you'll realize very
quickly that your sense of touch and
your sense of hearing really pale in
comparison to your sense of vision and
people say that your visual capabilities
take about 30% of your brains cortex
where maybe hearing is only 8% feel and
touch only 3% so the the primary use of
your brain is really vision and if you
look at the extension of your brain
cells that capture light and are
sensitive to light in your eyes and then
trace millions of paths through back to
your occipital lobe you find out lots of
amazing things about what the brain can
do with vision and neuroscientists of
course have been studying that for many
decades and then a little while back
maybe 30 40 years ago computer
scientists thought what if we create a
model of a neuron what if we put numbers
and calculate based on what the
neuroscientists are doing and kind of
mimic that and have computer algorithms
that can mimic the human brain thus AI
was born and I was born quite a long
time ago but it wasn't until recently
that we have enough computing power to
do AI so it's an exciting topic there
are new chip technologies for AI that I
want to be talking about today but I'd
like to step back and first tell you why
this is so important and why it's
interesting also how it works and how
people are starting to examine these
kinds of problems and then maybe finally
what some examples are and then you'll
be experts at the end and you'll be able
to go lecture everyone you know about AI
in edge computing so let's get started
some disclaimers about the numbers that
you'll see in the in the talk here today
so professor Dasher gave a brief
introduction so when I'm not playing
jazz what I like to do is work on micro
processors and as he said I have some
international experience I started out
working for a company in Osaka called
Panasonic Matsushita at the time
they changed their name and came to
Stanford to work for the u.s. Technology
Management Center but the processor
technology always seemed really exciting
to me and in the year 2000 there was a
really brilliant Renaissance where
people decided you know what we don't
have to build the whole chip we're gonna
buy from somebody who designs a piece of
the chip we'll license a piece of the
chip and we'll license another piece of
the chip and so suddenly the IP industry
intellectual property in the context of
semiconductors meant that a group of
people two people can design a video
codec in their basement licensed it to
IBM that actually happened and then I
could be looking at the IBM chip and
testing it and realizing wait this audio
codec something's wrong with it and then
the people at IBM say well we licensed
it from a third party so it was a really
interesting thing that I saw when I was
working at Dolby Laboratories that a lot
of the chips we were getting and testing
and supporting the pieces and parts of
those chips were actually IP coming from
other third parties and so I thought
this is a brilliant way to design chips
I want to jump in and get into that and
I went to go work for ten silica as an
audio systems engineer and the rest is
history
but it wasn't long before I got into
video processing and of course video is
important but eventually vision became a
very very important problem because
there's a lot of things you can get from
video if you extract meaning from the
video frames that are being captured so
something else I can say movie deus was
a company that was pretty early on
designing a chip that could actually do
camera processing and some computer
vision technology at the same time and
there were some other companies doing
that as well and now nowadays if you say
computer vision just about everyone
seems to keep working on computer vision
technology so let me step back a second
and just define what edge computing is
because I think looking at most of the
speakers that are speaking in this
series there's a variety of definitions
that you might want to look out for so I
thought I'd give you a little bit of a
roadmap when you're talking about edge
computing with your friends and family
over the weekend you can
you can understand a little bit more so
we start at the network edge where there
are devices or things and their network
so the key aspect of an edge device is
that the fact that it's connected to a
network it could be called a connected
device they have sensors they're getting
information and of course they could be
doing some computing but they also could
be sending it into the data center and
it has to travel through sometimes an
edge compute device so here I brought an
edge compute device it's a very small
industrial PCE
these kinds of edge servers are used for
edge computing and you can see it's very
small it's it's low power it's cheap it
can fit inside a small retail store you
don't necessarily have to send the
camera data into the cloud to get
processed when you can do computing in
the edge so we'll talk more about edge
computing of course so you're
aggregating the data from the sensors
you're doing some computing and then
it's connected to a network
infrastructure
it could be wirelessly talking to a base
station now the base station is
interesting because if I were in 5g or
telecom I would be saying the base
station is the edge and so from a
telecom or 5g point of view the telecom
edge is or the comms edge is the base
station but from the IOT and devices and
micro processors point of view the edge
is really the network edge where all the
sensors are and coming into these edge
servers so there's a lot of different
terminology but essentially it's mostly
about you know where the sensors are
capturing data if you're doing the
compute there then you're doing edge
computing and then you have the data
center so many of you who maybe use an
Alexa at home you're talking actually to
the data center and then the data
centers doing the compute and sending it
back and it seems fairly low latency but
actually it's a very long latency
there's a lot of power being consumed
and so when you do computing at the edge
you get immediately results you could
have very low latency low power privacy
there's a lot of benefits to doing edge
computing and we'll go into a little bit
more detail but basically lower cost and
power is the whole goal so let's move on
I like to cease to
mystics about how much data were
generating at the edge because if you
think of vehicles as edge devices which
they are they have sensors if you think
of airplanes if you think of edge
cameras or set our smart city buildings
anywhere their sensors and data coming
in we have billions of gigabytes of
information or zettabytes data that's
being generated by the year 2025 a
hundred zettabytes is quite a lot of
data and the problem today that
businesses are finding is that if they
don't take advantage of checking out
that data and processing that data then
they're missing out on opportunities to
make their businesses more efficient why
is that important well take for example
a fast food fast food company that wants
to make its french fries very quickly
and maybe they don't want to waste oil
or they don't want to waste food or you
know to minimize waste wouldn't it be
great if you knew who was coming into
the lot when and how many people were
coming into the lot how many people were
coming through the door how many people
were coming into line and you could
pretty much develop models as long as
you can track those people to figure out
how many exactly how many french fries
you should be preparing so that you're
not making too much you're not making
too little this kind of information that
you're gathering at the edge through
cameras can actually be used to reduce
the cost of running your business if
you're running a whole chain of
thousands and or tens of thousands of
fast-food restaurants so it's a really
serious problem for businesses how can
they cut cost and yet be efficient and
yet serve people really quickly before
the french fries go stale so that's just
one example but it's really transforming
the way we live and work in a lot of
different ways edge computing is
improving quality of life in smart home
many of you may have smart devices
operating your lights or various kinds
of systems at home in agriculture in
public safety there are a lot of ways in
which edge computing and gathering data
in sensors using that data wisely can
help with efficiency with safety with
lowering cost if you think about we'll
talk a little bit more about and
drill machinery and industrial
manufacturing we're finding a product
defect is very important you do not want
product defects getting into your
products today it's with a lot of manual
labor that you can find defects maybe at
a rate of let's say 7080 percent
depending on how complex the product is
if you're a human being but now put in
cameras and then you can get up to 99
percent or higher accuracy and finding a
product defect just by having a robotic
arm quickly take pictures of the device
now is it replacing the human doing the
manual labor
maybe but is it creating a lot more jobs
to maintain the robot and maintain the
cameras and maintain and watch the
system yes so it's not necessarily a
robot taking over a job to do it more
efficiently it's creating some jobs as
well so there's an interesting now angle
to be looking at industrial
manufacturing now let's click one more
level below and see what kinds of things
are taking advantage of edge computing
in various kinds of applications for
industrial I talked about machine vision
over there in smart cities analyzing
traffic parking license-plate
recognition is a very popular algorithm
that you would implement some of you
know LPR is license plate recognition
emergency response people counting for
you know an ATM at the at the bank or if
you're walking into a bank knowing how
many people are walking in and out and
using the ATM reducing wait time by
having some customer feedback or some
maybe facial recognition at the ATM not
because it's going to be sending your
face to the police but it's because it's
looking at your sentiment and giving you
extra help or maybe connecting you with
someone live if you seem to be having
trouble or you're looking like you're
frustrated so there's a lot of
interesting AI algorithms that could be
put to use in edge computing to improve
your experience and in transportation of
course autonomous vehicles have tons of
sensors various kinds of modes lidar
radar vision sensing to be able to take
you along and Hanul eyes the world
around you so those are just some
examples now AI technology in general is
growing very very
fast if we look at some analysts that
have estimated the growth of AI
technology we're talking about fifty
billion dollar here down here where we
are and then growing in terms of you
know hundreds of billions of dollars
over the next few years so we believe
that it will create about thirteen
trillion dollars of additional economic
activity just in the next ten or eleven
years so there's actually a lot of
activity in many different industries
going on with AI and one question you
may be asking is why why now why not
forty years ago and these kinds of
models of human brains were invented I
think it's because the compute capacity
that we have today in microprocessors
that can fit in a very small box or in a
small device or maybe even on your wrist
or in a cell phone there's a lot more
compute capacity and it's basically
reached a point where some very basic
and very high accuracy AI algorithms can
be implemented in a very small low-power
microprocessor so we've sort of reached
a point where the computing capacity
required for very accurate AI algorithms
that are valuable in these kinds of
businesses you can now get for five or
ten dollars and put in a small device so
how does AI work I thought I would
explain maybe in one or two slides what
AI is all about so that you can all
become PhDs very soon in the topic so AI
is actually the mimicking of a human
brain a very general kind of topic but
if you dig down into various aspects of
AI there's something called machine
learning a subset of AI where a machine
is actually iterating and maybe there's
some error in a robot trying to tie a
shoelace but it gets better and better
as it tries to reduce the error and so
it's learning or quote-unquote learning
so reducing error in a machine algorithm
is machine learning but more
specifically when you get to something
called deep learning that's where you
hit the ability to do machine learning
but in a very regimented way with these
kinds of model neurons and layers of
these neurons that look something like
this so you do a lot of multiply in ads
and just may be similar to the way a
human brains and
we'll chemically either react or not
react you're basically passing passing
through information from layer to layer
and what's called a deep neural network
so deep learning is all about
implementing a deep neural network and
these actually have been tuned many many
many people have been doing research on
deep neural networks for decades and so
they're very efficient way on a
microprocessor in multiply in editions
to be able to implement an algorithm
that does machine learning so there are
two steps the first is you train the
algorithm now if the algorithm is let's
say recognizing an object you might take
photos or pictures digitized of objects
humans bicycles strawberries many many
many of these photos pass them through
and set start to set the parameters of
the neural network
so once the neural network parameters
are set you can then decide ok now I'm
going to do what's called the inference
step we're actually going to deploy the
neural network and I'm going to put
unknown images inside then when it sees
an unknown images with the parameters
that have already been set in the
training step you would then be able to
get out you know what classification so
the classification in this case might be
bicycle it might be incorrect it might
be correct in some cases you have to go
retrain if you want to improve your
accuracy but improving your accuracy
means you may need more layers of
neurons you may need higher accuracy
neural network that uses let's say
floating-point 32-bit floating-point
instead of sixteen bit floating point
instead of 8-bit integer so there are
various ways and various kinds of
magical ways in which people are
training neural network algorithms to be
able to do very useful kinds of things
like object tracking like classification
like detection and those kinds of things
on images so this is I'm just focused
right now on the imaging aspect of AI so
that's it training and inference when
you're deploying or creating you know
camera based implementations you would
be performing inference and many people
will ask what's the performance of the
inference how many inferences can you do
in one second how many inferences can
you do in a watt of power how many
inferences can you do in this much cost
in this much space and so the inference
performin
is what people will ask when you're
trying to deploy the the product or the
the the thing or the device or the
server that's actually going to be out
in the field but in order to develop the
developers back in the lab will spend
days or weeks or months actually
training algorithms this is where you
need a lot of compute power you need to
be running many many images through
hundreds of millions of images large
datasets and so this is why people buy a
very large data center grade CPUs GPUs
FPGAs all kinds of accelerators that are
more suited for the data centers so that
when I'm connected to the data center
and I'm doing my training algorithm
it'll spend maybe I'm only spending a
week instead of two weeks so there's the
training which is an offline kind of
developer step and then finally when you
deploy the equipment the inference so
hopefully that explain it now you're all
experts the the key thing about AI
though is traditionally you would write
like face recognition algorithm or a
face tracking algorithm or object
tracking algorithm let's say for a
point-and-shoot camera and you would
write the algorithm it would be a human
engineered algorithm and using a model
of a face and you know you would write
it in C code let's say and rent would be
running in an embedded system but these
algorithms never really got too accurate
and the great thing about AI is that the
accuracy of a I now can far surpass what
a human engineered algorithm could be
now there is a downside though it takes
quite a lot of arithmetic so if you have
the microprocessor capability to be able
to run as much arithmetic as you need to
run the AI algorithm then you can get
amazing amount of accuracy and here
there's a little graph showing what deep
learning has been able to do in terms of
the error of detecting people or
tracking people it's now the error is
lower than a human set of eyes so if
you're watching video and you're being
asked where are the people in the video
that today a computer algorithm running
an AI a computer running an AI algorithm
can do it better than a human so
algorithms have become very very
accurate of course the cost is in terms
of the compute so if you only have a
very like
if toy company wanted to create dolls
that had some kind of image processing
inside I guarantee you would be a human
engineered algorithm running in a very
very low amount of memory that's
suitable for a toy they wouldn't
necessarily choose an AI algorithm but
if it's a camera in a car that needs to
detect pedestrians and brake
automatically it would it be a human
engineered algorithm you would probably
get much better results with with an AI
algorithm but they would still have to
develop it to get close to or maybe
equal to a hundred percent accuracy in
the case of pedestrians and so I'm still
on the question of why why is this
important the opportunity in computing
chip technologies in edge computing
chips is actually an interesting kind of
chart to look at and I spent some time
extracting some information that we had
looked at at Intel from various analysts
and from our own analysts at Intel to
come up with I couldn't give you the
numbers of this because some of its
internal information but suffice it to
say that over the next few years over
the next five years or so there's going
to be a growth in the endpoint device
and edge computing edge servers that do
the inference but there's also going to
be a surge in training and the ability
and the amount of silicon people are
going to need to train the algorithms
the question is which is growing faster
and as it ends up what these analysts
had found is that there's about a 25 to
30% 35% growth in AI overall but the
growth is actually larger for both the
endpoint and edge inference and compared
to in the data center so the edge is
growing really fast and that's because I
think it's because in a lot of different
industries companies and businesses are
making really good use of edge computing
and so there's a lot of silicon now in
the last few years being shipped for
agriculture and for visual retail and
for medical imaging and all kinds of
things if you go for an x-ray how many
people still have doctors that maybe
produce the film or actually go into a
lab for the film that still exists and
it's inexpensive
some hospitals are now investing into
digital x-rays and so you can do edge
computing very quickly that way so what
are the benefits of edge computing and
what are the very strict requirements
well the requirements are a bit heinous
because you need to have huge compute
requirements if you're going to be
running let's say a pedestrian detection
in your car you can't just have a little
16-bit controller that's you that's
running your refrigerator at home it
actually needs to be quite a beefy
processor that's running these
computations to be able to perform the
AI algorithm it with a lot of accuracy
and the more accurate the algorithm the
many more layers that it has it's not
uncommon to have neural networks that
have hundreds of layers of neurons and
if you imagine like a 200 by 200 pixel
image that's 40,000 inputs that you need
each pixel gets its own input into the
neural network so these are really
really big neural networks with a lot of
compute performance required trillions
of operations per second required from
these neural networks you also require
low latency of course if you're going to
let's say fly a drone and it's going to
detect an issue and you're going to have
to do some computation and send the data
back in real time you have to do all
that computation in real time or you're
going to end up accumulating data and
then you have to do something with the
data so multispectral cameras that are
very expensive and that are sitting on
farms an alternative is to actually have
smaller multi spectral cameras flying
around so you can detect where the crops
are being damaged or you can detect
various things going on where the rotten
tomatoes are in the field but you have
to do something with that data you can't
just accumulate it on the drone you have
to be able to compute really quickly and
have very low latency you also need
power efficiency power efficiency power
is an interesting thing because it
generates heat so in order to build a
box that has a lot of performance you
have to make sure that you're using very
good power efficient silicon or else
it'll generate too much heat it also
means more cost because then the board's
carrying the silicon will have to be
further apart and so you have larger
boxes because there's more heat so power
efficiency is really key but you also
have to be able to
compute quite a lot so these are
basically trade offs that we're looking
at and then the other thing is privacy
keeping the data on premise if you
imagine an edge computing device that's
able to track people coming in and out
of a store a convenience store and track
what people are buying and it's a staff
'less convenience store you wouldn't
necessarily want to walk into the store
if you knew that the camera was sending
your data into a data center but you
might walk into the store knowing that
maybe your privacy's is is pretty good
because the data is being computed in
real time and your data is not even
being stored it's just be used to
accumulate some statistics of you know
where you're moving around in the store
where the hot spots are for customers or
how many people are coming in and out
but to the extent that you can keep the
data on-premise in an on-premise server
you don't necessarily need to be
communicating over the network sensitive
data like you know tracking people and
things like that and so what is the chip
innovation required to meet those needs
and those very strict requirements this
is where the action is and this is why I
titled this talk the edge is where the
action is because the edge requirements
for doing this heavy compute in low
latency with low power is actually
causing us to have to build chips that
are very very efficient moving data
around and having very efficient data
flow on the chip we also have to build
better algorithm processing we need to
be using memory more efficiently because
memory isn't free even if they're very
small chips and the silicon process
technology is still an issue so Gordon
Moore's law of trying to improve the
size of the transistor in order to get
more speed from a chip is still there's
tons and tons of investment in that kind
of problem so there's still a lot of
challenges in the chip industry in order
to meet the need for this insatiable
desire to deploy AI algorithms
everywhere because of course there's a
cost to being able to deploy such
complex algorithms to get very high
accuracy and so how exciting is AI today
I thought I would explain by
transporting you to August 2019 to the
hot chips conference which was over in
mem on and it was a very exciting
conference but
Cerre was an interesting turning point
for the hot chips conference when I
attended it ended up that there was a
number of new deep learning chips being
announced and if you looked at the last
few years you know AI was becoming kind
of an interesting thing there were some
some companies starting to dabble with
AI and announced new chips in AI but not
like this August when there were this
many inference chips being announced
Intel Habana Huawei Nvidia and Tesla and
there were just about as many training
chips being announced as well so there
was something like ten or eleven or nine
AI disclosures all happening at the same
conference which made it practically an
AI chip conference even though still we
had the big CPUs and GPUs and other
other kinds of devices so and there's a
mix of startups and large companies a
lot of innovation going on in AI I
thought it would be interesting to show
with show you and you can go to the hot
chips org website and review these
papers and you can even watch on YouTube
they have links to the presentations so
let me give you some examples of real
things going on because I'm now going to
switch to the aja topic in my talk today
of things going on here and in Asia
first ai dev kits have become available
recently um this is an example of Intel
based dev kits but the just the idea of
a development kit being sold as opposed
to just use the computer that you're
already using shows that people aren't
satisfied with just your laptop or
desktop PC you want something faster you
want something more efficient so if
you're gonna train a neural network your
laptop may not be fast enough but if you
go buy one of these accelerator cards
inside of one of these Intel mini pcs
then you'll be able to work on your
prototyping of AI algorithms in a much
more efficient way also some companies
are putting together like this
development kit called the neural
compute stick that we developed and
putting it with a little atomic pipe car
PC so this is just an example of what
what we're doing at Intel but it's
interesting to look in Asia at different
kinds of development kits and
technologies that are coming to market
now a very recent one that has already
been made public is the AI development
kit called vision seed by 10 cent maybe
many of you are familiar with this
company from China there even though
that it's kind of a cloud services
company and you know applications
company having a dev kit with multiple
sensors and an AI accelerator on board
it's the Intel accelerator so I you know
I've been involved in this project but
it's really interesting to see such a
small a AI accelerator card that anybody
any developer can go get and start to
develop with create a robot create you
know a drone that has computer vision an
AI and they're not alone there are many
companies now developing these kits to
be able to get developers maybe even in
colleges and graduate schools to start
learning how to program on their
platform another example oh there are
many more examples I was going to talk
about at Intel we have an ecosystem of
developers we're pretty much with open
arms taking in relationship building
relationships with a lot of developers
many of these are in Asia a number of
them are either hardware developers in
countries like Taiwan in Japan in Korea
in other parts in India and these
partners are either creating software so
that they can run on various kinds of
development platforms very specialized
AI algorithms we'll talk a little bit
about the kinds of AI algorithms people
are developing as well as hardware cards
and boards that are based on various
kinds of chip technologies so and some
of them are integrators integrating the
hardware technology and so there's a
whole big ecosystem or channel where an
end customer like a fast-food restaurant
would go to a system integrator the
system integrator would know which kinds
of hardware technologies to be and
software technologies to be using and so
there's a big chain of developers that
are starting with some silicon starting
with some software tools and then
developing Hardware boards that go into
industrial pcs or servers like this one
and then ultimately get set into the end
customer's business to help out so this
is our channel partner ecosystem in the
IOT group at Intel that I'm showing I'll
focus on one of them in a second but
let's let me just share with you another
example a couple of companies in Taiwan
that are developing PCI cards and it
sounds very simplistic like of course
you would take a chip and you would
develop a PCI card with it but when an
customer want or as systems integrator
wants to be building these AI systems
for the customers they have to come get
their hardware somewhere and different
hardware has different features some of
them are built to the PCIe
specifications so that they can be put
like in this PC this industrial PC that
I was showing before and some of them
are smaller cards so they can go into
much more smaller places like into a
camera to make a camera so whether it's
an industrial PC or industrial edge
computing server or a camera there are
different kinds of hardware developers
that are in the ecosystem in Asia that
are you know kind of tackling this kind
of problem is getting a piece of the AI
business by building cards and building
and supporting the customers so I'm
going to show you a video of this exact
it's not going to have the sound but
it's this server actually running a
partner software they're called gorilla
and this box itself is from a company
called ie I so ie AI builds the box and
builds the boards that have the Intel
chips on one of the cards and then the
gorilla software is actually running 16
cameras worth of AI so 16 cameras are
connecting into the box and where you
see me demonstrating this on the table
it's this exact box here and the data is
coming out of memory instead of
streaming from a camera a real camera
but you could you can have a car license
plate detection car traffic detection
looking at which cars and then
classifying the cars and looking at what
determining what model of car they are
and so there's a lot of car and traffic
related AI algorithms that could be
running we
an average two or so of these AI models
algorithms on each chip and they're
eight chips on the board so there's 16
channels of AI algorithms running in the
in the device and then people are being
tracked and so it's for public safety
and traffic and it's this kind of
software could go in a small like a
compute facility that's near the side of
the road so the cameras that are near
the road or on over the road don't
necessarily have to send video all the
way into the data center it can go
through a 5g connection to write to a
local computer with a small number of
these servers and then you're getting
that local areas worth of metadata that
you can then share with other parts of
the city and then you can kind of
imagine that in the next few years those
kinds of systems would allow for better
traffic congestion dealing with the
traffic congestion a warning your
automated in once cars more autonomous
cars are on the road then it becomes a
bit of an autonomous system but we'll
see you know right now researchers are
writing papers about these kinds of
systems and they're just starting to be
deployed along with the 5g
infrastructure so that was one example
and so now I'll talk about sort of the
you know what are we doing and what are
the devices that you'll actually see in
some of these systems moving from the
edge devices to the edge servers into
the cloud this really gives a summary of
the Intel product line and what I'm
showing here is on the Left what the
edge devices are using these moe videos
chips this came from the startup I was
working for and we've been now
developing new generations of these
chips and the important thing about the
edge devices especially ones that are
going into cameras that you get a lot of
performance and you have very low power
so the absolute performance comparison
against a data center chip you know
there's there's not a very good
comparison at all but if you look at the
performance per watt of power or the
performance per watt of power per dollar
of cost that's where these things really
shine because you have a very limited
amount of power you couldn't put a data
center processor from over here into a
camera it wouldn't work
you know because of just the sheer
wattage required from the data center
processors so then you have these edge
servers like this one here and larger
edge servers depending on if it's
hundreds of cameras at an airport wing
then you need a larger server than this
one this would only take about 8 or 16
cameras and then you would use these
Intel processors that are very similar
to the ones in your laptop but you put
them on a card and then you add to it
some acceleration like either from the
movie Dias chip or from an FPGA and then
you can get a lot more AI performance
out of out of your small edge server or
your gateway there's a new class of
product called an AI box or AI appliance
where you basically already have an
infrastructure for a server or you have
an NVR that's basically collecting data
from cameras now you want to just
connect up to a smart intelligent device
that can then do analytics on 32
channels or 64 channels of video and
these kinds of AI appliances are now
being built by many different companies
we find the most aggressive ones are in
Asia coming to market very quickly with
small boxes that have quite a lot of AI
performance in them and then of course
in the data center you also want to be
running AI in many cases you're
detecting or cropping an image but then
sending it for classification into the
cloud so the classification engines that
could be running in the data center can
be quite sophisticated if you think
about a supermarket how many products
are on the shelf at a supermarket how
many different labels have to be
analyzed if you want any label of any
product to be recognized by a
classification engine that's the kind of
algorithm that you would run in the data
center but to detect the person and to
detect when the person is grabbing the
product and putting it in their cart
that's something that you can do at the
edge so you would have AI algorithms
running in the edge
another ai algorithm running in the data
center to be able to do a staff list or
so you it's not always whether you're in
the edge or in the data center you
usually need to be partitioning
algorithms among the different resources
putting the appropriate very heavy
algorithms in the data center that need
to do the classification the
very appropriate edge algorithms that
are doing the detection and a little bit
lighter in terms of performance so I
will explain now how the movi Gnaeus
chip works I recently was able to do a
video and I was really excited to do
this video because it's really hard to
actually explain without using a lot of
CG how the chip works so I thought I
would just spend a minute maybe I should
fast-forward to the middle of the video
because you're not hearing can i
fast-forward oh maybe I can't
fast-forward but anyway the idea of the
movie do silicon is that you have a lot
of performance and very low power so
roughly three or four trillion
operations per second in about a water
to of power and the way that you get
there is by minimizing the data movement
on the chip so the the it would seem
like the more compute you have the more
power it would consume but the power is
mostly consumed by getting data in and
out of memory and moving data around on
the chip so the team when they founded
the company they thought there's
probably a lot of room we have to lower
the power if we can only figure out
better ways to move data around so in a
traditional chip where your licensing IP
and you have CPUs and GPUs and DSPs that
are integrated on to the chip they
usually have data buffers and the data
is moving around from these data buffers
that causes some power to be dissipated
but on the move idiots architecture we
actually have a scratchpad memory that
everything is connected to so because
this is multi ported you can get CPUs
DSPs and other accelerators to be moving
data around minimally because the data
is really sitting in place in this
scratchpad memory so as your algorithm
and use your application algorithm
kernels are running you can manage where
the data is coming from and where it's
going to and as long as you're managing
that appropriately you're minimizing how
much data movement actually has to
happen and then if you could take a
bunch of these chips and you can put
them on boards the other trick to
building these chips is that you have to
have kind of a heterogeneous set of
resources because computer vision and AI
requires not just deep learning to
happen but people may have customized
algorithm they need to run on general
purpose processors so we have DSPs that
were optimized for computer vision as
well as some engines that were optimized
to run hardwired algorithms so they're
very efficient and one engine in
particular that was built from the
ground up to run neural networks so it
can run several different neural
networks which you would run a run from
some video sources and you would want to
run those neural networks at the same
time you're running computer vision and
everything else on the chip so the fact
that the chip has a lot of parallel
computing and that it's trying to lower
power makes it a pretty efficient engine
and then if you put eight chips onto a
board and you put several boards into an
edge computing PC it's quite a powerful
PC that could have many of these chips
running tens or hundreds of trillions of
operations per second and then we wrap
up this software that I'll talk about a
little bit more but that's basically
what the the moe video chip is doing now
let's shift back to some interesting
companies in Asia so I was trying to
think how can I not have some examples
from other parts of Asia Japan so this
company leap mind is very interesting
they make they're able to make
convolutional neural networks or deep
neural networks a lot more compact and
that's very tricky
how can you remove a lot of computation
from an algorithm and still get the same
results or still get the same accuracy
well they've created some research and
patents and they're able through some
tricks to be able to get compressed
algorithms running on smaller engines
maybe even in an arm or small CPU on a
cell phone weary
let me interrupt you I'm sorry that our
speaker on November 14 is no oh we might
we might know yeah fantastic
so this is a good example you'll hear
more about it if you come to that event
thanks professor - right a company that
I worked for based in Tokyo morpho Inc
has combined a lot of photography and
imaging capabilities with deep learning
to be able to do much better imaging
quality on lower performance processors
like in a cell phone so they started out
by being able to do various kinds of
image and video stabilization on a cell
phone using it
and software algorithms and now they're
doing a lot of AI and implementing
computational photography using AI and
they won an award at the recent embedded
vision summit for a product of the year
so I finally you know the last few
minutes of my talk I wanted to talk
about trends that I'm seeing moving
forward I think from the vantage point
of a big company building silicon and
we're supplying in a lot of markets or
supplying in a lot of different regions
of the world and there's some trends I'd
like to point out these aren't
necessarily market trends but certainly
chips are really worth nothing unless
the software works so the software is
actually the critical piece in getting
silicon deployed in efficient ways that
various businesses can take advantage so
when you think about the software
journey that people are taking in order
to implement whether it's AI or whether
it's just about any application you need
to explore and do research and you need
to prototype you need to optimize your
code for the platform that you plan to
run it on and then you deploy the
algorithm and so what I'm seeing is a
trend among a lot of different companies
to have more and more efficient tools so
that developers can get from exploring
to prototyping to optimizing and
deploying really really quickly and it's
not like we're trying to cut corners
we're actually trying to give more power
to the developer and at Intel we have a
tool suite that was announced a year ago
called open vino that is able to take
people's neural networks algorithms and
then port them to any architecture that
we have it Intel and other companies as
well are working on specialized tools
that will be able to allow you to
prototype and get to market very quickly
and I think that's very interesting and
it also goes hand in hand with all the
developer kits that comfort different
companies are coming out with to make it
really easy and the byproduct of that
means that if you're at a university
your graduate student and you don't just
want to use your desktop to run all of
your experiments you can quickly get
different tools and compare and contrast
performance across different
architectures or you can contract
compare and contrast your algorithms
running in different environments and
usually these tools are getting easier
and easier to use and the very macro
trend that I'm seeing if you look at
when I was a child and I was at the high
school programming on a machine that was
connected up to a mainframe and then you
look at how people were migrating more
to their desktops and now to mobile
devices and doing a lot of application
developments and mobile devices there's
also a trend that people are now as you
probably all know connecting to the
cloud and using cloud-based tools to
implement your algorithms so you don't
have to have the machine on your desk
anymore you could be connecting up using
various kinds of services and you know
any kind of cloud service and there are
tools that let you arrange your
algorithm implement them companies like
Google or offering environments to run
AI and to develop AI using their cloud
software and there's also hardware
accelerator FPGAs ai accelerators and
these boards you have access to because
you have access to the cloud and in
their data center they have a lot of
these accelerators plugged in so that
you have access to all of this hardware
without even leaving your PC at home so
or at school so the way in which people
are developing algorithms I see is
evolving basically making it easier on
the developer easier to access developer
tools easier to access them over the
cloud to implement them but of course at
the end of the day if you want to build
cameras that are going to be installed
in a fast food restaurant you really
need to develop the hardware but the
development journey is being made much
much more efficient another another
trend I wanted to point out that we had
Intel called workload consolidation is a
trend over that we've seen over several
years and I think it's going to continue
more and more in industries like
industrial automation where it used to
be you would have let's say a PC you
would have a camera like robots and then
data the robot would move things around
the P the camera would capture
information send it to the PC it would
then go over to another server now we
find that all of that functionality is
getting into one board in one PC or you
know connected to the cameras and in
some cases robots themselves are being
developed with the
camera in the robotic arm and the
compute inside the robotic arm so you
really just need the robotic arm to move
around and look in and count the number
of things going by or detect various
product defects and those kinds of
things so consolidating these workloads
that used to take a lot of different
resources across a whole company can be
put into like some small or medium-size
servers and have the consolidation of
all these different kinds of workloads I
think in different industries this will
be interesting to see how it evolves and
I think it's also an example of you know
how we're building our silicon to be
able to support multiple workloads some
general-purpose some working on pixel
data some doing computer vision so I'm
doing audio so we have all these
different resources that we're building
into the same silicon so I hope that
gave you a really good sense of why this
AI thing is very interesting and
important and why now how we're making
use of it in the industry for edge
computing and also what are some of the
different kinds of devices that we see
here and in Asia and I look forward to
doing much more where I've traveled to
Asia quite a lot it's an exciting place
it's very dynamic I think there's
definitely in the US and in Europe and
in Asia a lot of interest in AI but for
some reason the AI technology is really
taking off in Asia in a variety of
different ways that maybe we're not
seeing in the Western society but anyway
that's my talk happy to answer your
questions
so here let me ask the first question so
as somebody who's in the chip industry
do you see a difference in mood and the
chip industry you you can pointed out
the hot chips conference and how much of
the hot chips conference was a I would
you say that this is really breathing
new life into the industry well I do
yeah it's breathing new life because I
think there was a period of time where
startups weren't really getting funded
and then now because of deep learning
and computer vision and AI it's
breathing new life into a lot of
startups that were working on AI now
when I talked to when I talked to some
of the investors that are walking around
at hot chips show they were saying well
we don't really know who the winners and
losers are so that's the bad news is
it's really hard to tell you know is one
startup that builds a chip that's the
size of the wafer going to win or lose
it's really hard to tell but it's very
intriguing a company did actually build
a chip that's this big one chip per
wafer and no how do you package it how
do you cool it you know they're
basically breaking the rules in the
industry and inventing something new
that was Cerebrus so there's a lot of
companies that are getting funded and so
I think there's a there's kind of an
interesting Renaissance going on in like
algorithms that can do AI better and
it's it's to me it's still trudging
along at a pace you know but the fact
that a lot of new companies are
innovating and it's not just you know
the big companies there's a lot of
different are you interfacing with
different kinds of people when you're
when you're talking about Intel products
and so forth you're talking to a
different range of kind of industries or
do you see any changes there I well I
think they've always been their idea the
number of kind of roles people take on
when it comes to edge computing you have
data scientists and the data scientists
are just trying to figure out like what
data should we be analyzing how do you
train a neural network you can't ask
that question until you actually have
the data you need and so sometimes you
know you have to have a whole group of
data scientists that help feed the right
data to the engineers
are actually training the deep learning
algorithms so I think we're seeing a
different cross-section of Engineers
that it takes to come up with the right
algorithms in order to have something
like automatic pedestrian detection I
mean think about it I think it was I I
don't know exactly which car company it
was but when the first pedestrian
detection brake system came out I mean
it really was something because you know
the driver is supposed to be seeing the
pleasure sneeze all the time but in that
one little case where you might be
missing it
I'm the lied arse and radars and vision
sensors may not and so it's very
interesting that the development of
these algorithms now means there are a
lot of different kinds of computer
scientists and engineers and electronics
engineers required so I think I'm seeing
a different kind of cross-section of
people required to deploy this kind of
technology because different than just
having one camera company using silicon
that's been around for a long time and
then an installer that installs it now
there's a much larger ecosystem
different companies getting involved
building the Sun building software
hardware cards chips so many moving
parts I think so now we get into the
uncomfortable stuff so the computer chip
world has been very international world
sales and you know I think claw home was
selling 15 billion dollars of chips to
China for instance with all the things
happening the last few years are you
seeing decoupling are you really seeing
is the company kind of maybe not so much
talking about the direction of the
company or so for so forth because
that's probably sensitive but personally
are you seeing a different kind of mood
[Music]
well I like to think I'd like to think
and I think I've observed that in
technology people no matter where no
matter what country you're talking to
people in we all have the same goal we
want to build better technology to
improve people's lives so I think there
is a bit of a different mood when maybe
politics and governments kind of get
involved but I think still there's some
hope
well we're all just engineers we're just
living in different places and we want
to get along and kind of get make
technology better and I see that and so
it was interesting to see at the
Hutchins conference there was one
company that actually couldn't get visas
to attend the conference they were one
of the keynotes and they so they gave
the keynote via Skype so you know
technology solve the model and I
commended them for pushing past that
problem you know to be able to show up
at an international conference so that
people could hear their talk so I think
you know engineers or engineers you'll
find it you'll invite away around it
somehow huh Ok Go Ahead it's affecting
their startup ability and obviously
they're both in PRC and it's part of the
machine learning state so to extend on
his question is that part of the reason
why neisha things are much more advanced
because in Europe in the United States
there is a political and cultural
history that maybe is dissuading some of
that advancement that we you know like
for example license plate recognition in
Los Altos Hills and Los Altos there's
been a lot of controversy about we know
we can deploy it we know the sheriff
wants to use it but then people are
saying we don't want to use it and where
the taxpayer different places have
different senses of privacy clearly more
advanced versus less advanced I mean
there are developers all over the world
that are advanced so I wouldn't say one
place is more advanced than the other
but how technology is used and deployed
is very different from place to place as
you notice so we look exciting times for
sure and I think that's about all I can
say on that topic okay go ahead
yeah I just write for aged computing now
Tom's setting that how many 15 billion
dollars worked out
you know this computer that's CPUs GPUs
DSP cores on a dedicated right and cost
is a big factor right fresh computer you
can't put an expensive system out there
who why not tap into this wonderful
economy of skill that you know the
smartphone chips have and use that to
repurpose it for edge computed purposes
why can't heat an expensive or for
turning it's it's okay I mean if you're
afraid yeah I agree
you need you need more resource why not
you would happen to this economy of
scale you know it's very affordable
processors are very commonplace I
wouldn't say they're inexpensive though
so the mobile if you look at the cost of
a mobile phone processor it's not so
inexpensive actually people are looking
for less expensive silicon that can do
just as much as a mobile phone processor
which is why there are all of these
other kind of purpose-built custom chips
that are you know dedicated to AI let's
say when AI has to be just one of many
functions on a cell phone it has to
unlock given your face but it also has
to be running apps and games and other
things so yeah I think mobile mobile
phone chip companies you'll see are also
playing in this game of designing chips
for AI dedicated to various kinds of
other applications for edge computing
but it's not just a one to one like we
can take chips from a mobile phone and
they're immediately usable and in a
camera you know it's there's some
conversion some and in fact some of them
are expensive so you know if you don't
have water you it's going to affect your
economics that's true right so you
already have this great economy of skill
right billions of processors that are
already being manufactured mm-hmm
yeah I think it just depends on what you
what tapping into it really means I mean
those companies are also building
silicon for other things as well but I
mean a mobile phone has to have mobile
communication and there's special
features for the mobile phone that may
be other other kinds of computing needs
don't have so that's why there's some
customization required
like this kind of industrial PC server
I can't say it's not our product but
it's inexpensive I mean you could you
could buy you know you I mean if he
wanted to run your own software as a
service over a cloud and you wanted to
develop your own cloud you'd be buying
much more expensive servers so to do
enough that you need to do on-premise if
you run you know your own convenience
store this is this is good enough and
this is inexpensive enough so you don't
have to be investing in lots of high
performance data center kinds of data
center grade kinds of computers how much
of an acceleration can somebody get by
using say one of your system boards
system board with the mo videos
processors on it and what a drone or
something that's an interesting question
so a lot of customers will ask I have an
algorithm how much will it accelerate if
I use your silicon yeah yeah we have so
many different examples of customers
that have run on some basic CPU and then
they use our accelerator and they get a
hundred x or 183 X or you hundred so it
just depends on how efficient it was to
begin with and then where you currently
are what your algorithm is what platform
you're using um yeah there's a lot of a
lot of variables in that so it's hard to
give one answer okay go ahead so what do
you see the role future in City
photonics in this day i chip such as
silicon photonics base and chip as also
talking about the chip up or after each
graduate kolba
so if that's a Cobra which is a specific
Sonic you have a new system so what is
seeing the vision in City photonic being
this expert viewing to things I don't
work in that group but I should say in
the industry there are a lot of
interesting experiments being done on
how can we speed up computing lower the
power of computing as you say so looking
photonics
there's also neuromorphic computing a
lot of different kinds of
ways of implementing these algorithms
how promising they are I know one has a
crystal ball but it's really interesting
to see that a lot of these projects are
getting funded and we'll see how far
they go I can't tell you sorry about
that
which sounds very simple mm-hmm then
I'll watch the PBS Newshour running a
series on how successful facial
recognition is being applied to social
credit in detecting people who are
jaywalking and immediately putting their
faces up and publishing it Sara so is
there a disconnect between the US and
Asia in terms of sounds like the
innovations because pretty much at the
end of Moore's law for silicon it sounds
like most of the innovation is in what
massive parallel processing okay one
question at a time so is there a
disconnect when you're watching cats on
PBS being recognized by as an X well I
think it's an educational program so
they're going to give you a simple
example there's a famous example of a
bunch of blueberry muffins and a bunch
of dogs and the dogs kind of look like
the blueberry muffins and so can the AI
algorithm or can you as a human detect
the difference between them is it a
muffin or is it a dog these are used for
educational purposes I actually don't
think that you know is there a
disconnect between the way Asia is
deploying better facial recognition to
detect people jaywalking on the street
but you know on PBS no I think it's just
the way the technology is used
you'll see a lot more traffic cameras a
lot more jaywalking cameras because that
country the way the culture is they'd
like to do that and maybe Los Altos
doesn't want to do that so we have
various ways of deciding do we want to
deploy the technology or not and maybe
it's just a decision
of how to deploy the technology but it's
the same technology the question is how
much do we want to deploy it for
everyday use on every street corner here
versus an in a different city in a
different country and then you also
asked about the second question oh the
silicon yeah I know no that's a really
good point so I don't agree that it's
the end of Moore's Law I think there's
still a lot of innovation going on at
transistor level the physical technology
itself to be able to gain some
efficiency and speed up but there's also
a large amount of work being done in
architecture and how you organize the
transistors so I think there's bigger
gains to be had these days in the
silicon architectures and you'll find
different chips mo videos for example
came up with a different kind of way to
develop the chip and that's how we were
able to get a good efficiency so there's
new kinds of technologies some of the AI
startups for example are putting memory
close to the compute engines and they
have a lot of local memory memories
being put near the compute engines more
expensive maybe a little bit different
kind of architecture but different kinds
of architectures are going to get much
much more gains not just the silicon
technology but I think there's still
room for growth in both areas so you're
asking about the fundamental differences
between CPUs and the vpu that we
developed well in the case of process
technology no no the same process
technology is being used if the
architecture that's very different CPUs
even GPUs have to be fairly
general-purpose the VP use were designed
specifically for a computer vision so
they're kind of purpose-built for
computer vision so one of the things you
mentioned one of the trends you
mentioned at the end of your talk was
workload consolidation
putting different functions into one
device instead of multiple devices is
that basically because of the time it
takes to communicate across device
boundaries or what's driving that I
think it's because of the total cost of
ownership okay but also different
protocols are being used it's easier to
have the data within a chip or within a
board or within a PC but yeah it's
combination of maybe efficiency and cost
and speed and accuracy I mean all of
these different things that weigh in to
the requirements overall for edge
computing but yeah I don't think there's
just one driver of that okay other
questions go ahead regional use cases
it's hard to say there are specifically
please region focuses on some you
traffic cameras is an interesting
example in China because there's just a
prevalence of traffic cameras but hmm
Japan has a heavy big industry of
factory automation FA and robotics and
so I think I've seen use cases some of
them were gonna see if the Olympics
which is really interesting some of the
big sponsors of the Olympics coming up
in Tokyo may demonstrate various kinds
of interesting technology in robotics
and automation in Toulon we see a lot of
the board design and ODMs and kind of
the companies that are in the middle of
the channel we're building the silicon
and other companies building the silicon
supplying them to build the machines
that are then getting integrated into
the end customer so not as many end
customers not as many silicon companies
but definitely a lot of the people and
companies that are in the middle of the
channel in Korea in India there are a
lot of companies that I don't know why
it seems that the number of companies
that I know build the dev kits there are
a number of them in India who do that
very well and then they label them as
you know a TI dev kit or an Intel dev
kit and so taking the software smarts I
think that has been built up over the
years I mean I would say
in India so there's a lot of companies
that have very large software teams
enables maybe better use of you know
using the silicon to build dev kits and
development platforms but I I don't know
if that's a regional specialty because
there are other dev kits coming from
elsewhere as well but yeah that's a hard
question to answer because I don't think
it's regional I think forever there's a
density of engineers there's going to be
a lot of interesting new AI technology
that's right to assist the elderly so
yeah maybe that's one of the factors
that contributes to the robotics in
Japan so I'm going to go back to this
decoupling once and I'm seeing news
articles that the result of putting
companies on the entity list so that the
US companies can't do business with them
is basically going to encourage Chinese
companies to ramp up their chip
development activities and have lots of
new competitors maybe although I've I've
seen that everywhere there's ramping up
of chip design capability so there are
chip chip developers all over the world
I would say since more startups are
getting funded I know of some AI
startups from Canada now that I didn't
know of just a year ago various
different regions so I would say maybe
you're right but maybe there's just all
so many chip companies popping up
everywhere so okay it's hard to tell
good yeah I don't know that's a
legitimate perspective thank you
products are made using the TSMC process
TSMC is one of the fabs that are used to
a very big one that's used to fabricate
chips and many people use TSMC there are
others as well but yeah that's one of
them intel has its own fabs as well but
yeah TSMC is another alternative
question in the back
yeah I think the the question is if AI
is meant to really improve people's
lives then what do chip companies like
the ones that had ships what are we
doing or what what can we do or how do
we measure how effective we are at
improving people's lives I think well
one thing to say is depending on the
size of the company like a small
start-up is really trying to get
something done to get you know get some
software running and demonstrate
something that's efficient or high
performance or low cost but larger
companies like Intel and other large
companies have the the reach to be able
to communicate with end customers and
communicate with the channel and learn
from what end customers are trying to do
so we have analysts and marketing people
talking with a lot of the end customers
so we're trying to find out you know
what what is their aim they're the ones
that know ultimately what what they're
trying to do to improve either the cost
of running a business or building
robotics for the elderly or here's a
really good case
so National Geographic is it in fact I
kept on telling myself I really should
talk about this example so I'm great I'm
glad you brought it up there were other
examples of this same technology but as
just one example there was a company
that wanted to build a camera and put
the cameras into the sub Saharan desert
to be able to detect a poacher before
the poacher kills the animal now the
current technology is that you detect
the sound of the gun so when the sound
of the gun is detected the authorities
can be alerted as to where that sound
came from but then it's too late
the animals dead so the idea is using
computer vision technology you can build
these cameras and National Geographic
and the Leonardo DiCaprio Foundation
have funded this company resolve to
build these cameras they're using our
Intel Nvidia chip
it's been publicized at CES we showed a
demonstration we built like a little
forest and essentially essentially it's
it's a really serious matter because you
could be saving tens or hundreds of
thousands of animals lives when you
detect the motion and then you decide
with your neural network is it an animal
moving or is it a human and if it's a
human then you send the data to the to
the you know if it's an animal you just
shut the camera back off so these
cameras have a battery length that's
quite long on the order of years and
they can be stuck in places where you
wouldn't see them but when the poachers
are walking by they're detected and then
the the Rangers that have to cover a
very very large amount of space so it's
a story that sort of gone viral in a way
and there other countries that are doing
similar things I think in China they're
trying to protect the bengal tigers and
their cut technology companies that are
building these kind of cameras but to me
this is definitely one of the ways in
which AI is being used for good but
there's a chain of you know the problem
is known locally and then they come to
the camera company the camera company
says yeah maybe we can solve the problem
and then they come to the device company
and so the device company is really just
hearing from our customers what do they
want to do and why and what do we feel
we need to support so there's a lot of
good interesting you know technology
that's being used for good it's just a
matter of taking the time to support
these companies to build the cameras and
get them deployed so it's an interesting
story and I think PBS even did a special
on those that particular company
actually I see several hands back in the
back good friends yeah you know that
kind of question is exactly what would
lead you to go compare and contrast
several different so go by the data
sheets for ten different chips and you
can measure it yourself there's no one
answer different chips running different
workloads will have different amount of
performance at different amounts of
power so but that's that's the kind of
spec people want to know and so it it
depends on a lot of different things how
your neural network was trained
how it's running what what neural
network is running what is that exactly
is it accomplishing how many inferences
per second and then how many you know
what's the power that's being consumed
or what's even power is sometimes the
wrong question you want to look at the
overall energy to complete a complete
job as opposed to the power at any
moment which could be fluctuating so
there's no one answer but it is the
right question there's just no one
answer so in about a watt or so of power
it can run at a you know typically a
couple of trillions of operations per
second something like there's typical
benchmark neural networks that will do
this kind of a job whether it's Alex net
which is fairly simple and a little bit
older or something more recent like
Google net or the most recent benchmark
that everyone seems to be using is
called ResNet 50 resident 50 is a is a
fairly sophisticated algorithm that can
do tracking of objects or faces or
people fairly efficiently so yeah it
also depends on like what has it been
trained on or how you're running it and
what what's the data the whether you're
running it in 4-bit mode or 8-bit or
16-bit or 32-bit or floating-point 16
floating-point 32 so there's a lot of
different variables and knobs and
switches to how you're running the
algorithm let's quickly go a couple of
questions back in the back over here
yeah back in the very back
or about that economy from Persia Wow
so there's a Korean consortium that has
a bay area office am I thinking of Kotra
yeah yes if you go visit Kotra and just
walk through the hall you'll have many
many many different companies I'm not
going to name any individual ones
because then the others will come back
to me and say that's unfair why did you
mention there's a not mine but I would
say groups like Kotra or our make
facilitating companies from Korea to be
coming to the Bay Area and establishing
their presence here and working with
other companies so I would say that's a
good place to start look at the coach
our website go either for students or
hobbyists like analogous to like a red
berry party or we know or for people who
might want to run their own agents as
opposed to like Google's yeah after the
seminar I can tell you about a few
companies you can go contact if you want
to get some of these small industrial
pcs but you could also build them
yourself before we close up Gary you had
something you wouldn't say the students
here oh yeah in the marketing group that
I work in we might be hiring coming
coming to the end of the year an intern
for next spring so if you're interested
in engineering and you're very
technically minded but also interested
in marketing or sales or business that's
a really great combination if you're
interested in interning in our team
please contact me I have my business
cards thank you
and we have some refreshments afterwards
where you can initiate this kind of
conversation any rate thank you very
much for bringing this down to the level
of the chip which is really you know
this whole move toward edge computing is
causing changes all the way up and down
the technology stack and Gary really
appreciate you coming again
thank you